dr anthony fauci admitting over the
weekend
he moved the goal posts on the numbers
needed for covet herd immunity
watch i would imagine that you would
need something a little bit less than
the 90
that's where i got to the 85. bottom
line is
it's a guesstimate i gave a range and i
use any discussion like we're having now
dana to encourage
people to get to that goal of 70 to 85
percent of the people vaccinated
that's where we really want to be
joining me now is fox news contributor
and media and politics columnist for the
hill joe concha joe thanks so much for
being here on this monday
uh you just heard dr fauci what's your
take away from that
well i think that dr fauci needs to be
more careful with his language when you
start talking about
guesstimates when you start saying that
you deliberately move the goal post
you're no longer
the top infectious disease doctor in the
us
working off the data and working off the
science you're now just another guy on
tv
throwing darts and and look i think also
dr fauci needs to temper
his media appetite a bit he doesn't have
to say yes to every interview now that's
not to say that he shouldn't do
interviews at all but unless he has
something
essential to say he doesn't have to go
on national television and talk about
guessing this because
that doesn't exactly inspire confidence
from people that
may or may not be on the fence in terms
of taking this vaccine
and also dr fauci can learn to say i
don't know sometimes because again this
is a novel
virus it's an unprecedented situation
sometimes we just don't know what we
don't know
and instead he speaks with such
certitude on certain things like saying
for instance that the vaccine would not
be available
he virtually guaranteed it until many
months into 2021 and here we are
two companies already distributing that
vaccine so in the end
dr fauci does a tremendous service to
this country uh but he isn't perfect and
it's okay to criticize him once in a
while because he too can get it wrong
he did receive some criticism from
senator marco rubio
on twitter we can put that up here he
writes quote dr fauci lied about masks
in march dr fauci has been distorting
the level of vaccination needed for herd
immunity it isn't just taminian
elite bubbles believe the american
public doesn't know what's good for them
so they need to be tricked into doing
the right thing
my question is is there something to be
said for learning as we go
as you said it's a novel corona virus
even the top
experts in the world had to learn some
way along somewhere along the way
oh sure the world health organization
said what dr fauci said
dr jerome adams uh the surgeon general
said that mass
weren't necessary in march fauci later
clarified without apologizing but did
say
that well i was only saying that because
i wanted to protect frontline medical
workers
i didn't want to run on mass and that's
why i said that
but again when you say these things and
then later move the goal posts
or have to correct things after a while
public confidence in in
as you said an unprecedented situation
uh it even gets more shaky so yeah uh we
can learn as we go and
right now even though we have two
vaccines and we're 10 months into this
thing we still don't know everything
about
this disease or else we'd be able to
explain why california in a lockdown
has exploding cases in florida which is
relatively open uh
isn't doing relatively as badly so uh
yeah we're still learning alicia no
question
and i want to move on to something else
here because this ongoing battle between
cnn and the trump administration just
saw one more
blow by blow this past weekend take a
listen to um
jake tapper this weekend all right there
are some people that are such
they're just so mendacious i just
wouldn't put them on air
um kaylee mcaney i i never booked her
uh jason miller from uh the trump
campaign i would never book him i mean
these are just people who just
they just tell lies the way that you
know most people breathe
and there is no value in that
um at keeley mcinerney the white house
press secretary did respond on twitter
here's what she wrote
this is a therapy session for a broken
network and jake tapper is lazy enough
to participate by lobbying
baseless personal attacks with zero
evidence jake's real problem
i do not leak i do not lie but i do call
out the lies of the media iecnn russia
collusion
hoax joe i mean we're what weeks away
from a new administration and they're
just going to walk out the door
everyone's going to still be throwing
punches
yeah i'm not understanding this cnn had
hired caylee mcininney
as a political analyst before she became
white house press secretary and i would
imagine that's because they respected
her perspective
and didn't think she had a problem with
the truth because that would hurt the
network's credibility
the bottom line is and i'll leave it
here jake tapper used to book
michael avenatti personally somebody of
questionable character
adam schiff and swalwell it's it's
quite hypocritical thank you